hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the only show in the world that
blends competition humor and a host who
owns a ford fusion
it's a lease driving today's episode is
an all-time clash of classic creatures
so legendary their lineage can be traced
back almost 100 years and that's just
their cinematic legacy if you want to
incorporate mythology we'd have to start
with ancient egypt and make our way
through thousands of years while also
visiting transylvania a mysterious
laboratory and well the woods it's the
mummy versus dracula versus the
invisible man versus frankenstein versus
the wolfman in our universal monster
winner take all free for all
in one corner you have count dracula
whose universal run consisted of him a
son a daughter and star legends such as
bella lugosi and frank langella in the
title role next up it's frankenstein who
took a bride had a kid was a ghost and
met the wolf man said wolf person had a
house kicked it with abbott costello and
was most notably played by lon chaney jr
taking them on is um he's probably in
here somewhere the invisible man which
is actually a limiting term because
we're also including the invisible woman
here as well as the most recent film of
any in the field today 2020's accurately
titled the invisible man and wrapping
things up will be the mummy famous for
having a tomb a ghost a curse and a
sweet ride at universal studios they
really love some monsters in that studio
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three villains round four
it's alive
and then we'll do a wild card round that
may well come down to who would you
rather be a dashing fella whose only
drawback is that you get very itchy
during a full moon or an even more
attractive human who can occasionally
turn into a bat a creep who's invisible
and yes again maybe right next to me a
lumbering hulk with an abbey normal
brain or a revived ancient spirit that
is thousands of years old and brings
their own toilet paper to public
restrooms this is going to be the
bloodiest battle we've ever had on
verses let's get it on round one box
office today's match will be won
primarily on the strength of each
creature's classic universal movies
however this first round will more
likely be determined by the old adage
what have you done for me lately
box office that it can be spotty for
older flicks so if you've had a nice
revival in the last few decades that's
gonna be a solid leg up walking up to
the plate first is the invisible man
also known as the last great theater
experience i had before the pandemic hit
2020 had such promise back then and the
version starring the tremendous
elizabeth moss grossed 143 million
dollars at the worldwide box office
that's the good news the bad news is
that the most recent universal pick with
said unseen lee before that was in 1951
when he surprised abbott and costello
who's on first i don't know i literally
can't see i'll give the invisible
franchise credit for a 143 million
dollar average but even that gaudy
number pales in comparison to the mummy
we don't have box office records as far
back as 1932 when bella lugosi first
donned the shrouds but then in 1999
brendan frazier entered the chat and
since then all four theatrically
released mummy movies the mummy the
mummy returns the mummy tomb of the
dragon emperor and the mummy tom cruise
dates someone half his age each hauled
in over 400 million dollars worldwide
wow planet earth loves old curses over
1.67 billion dollars in total receipts
make for a 418 million dollar average
and this is the first time i can
accurately say brendon frazier more of
an awest star than maverick from top gun
juan cheney jr played the wolf man five
times but it wasn't until benicio del
toro took the fur over in 2010 that we
had reliable theater statistics and
while totaling 140 million dollars is
nothing to bark at it's gonna suffer the
same fate as the invisible man it didn't
have brendan fraser only two monsters
stand in the way of the mummy taking
this round easily but these monsters are
pretty famous dracula come on the dude's
a legend and that's not even counting
the times gary oldman and leslie nielsen
played the bloodsucker he's gonna be a
threat today for sure but between him
and frankenstein they only have one
flick that has trustworthy numbers
2014's dracula untold which starred luke
evans and notched 214 million dollars on
earth really that's a beefier take than
either the wolfman or the invisible folk
but nowhere near enough to disturb the
slumber of the mummy and yes if it feels
like this round was unfairly skewed
towards modern films when the peak of
universal monster movie making was over
70 years ago that's entirely fair but
we're about to peabody and sherman our
way back to that era for the next round
and when we do it'll be the mummy that's
on the scoreboard that franchise wins
round one and gets the first point of
the day round two tomato meter slash
audience score
if you're one of those people yelling
about a modern bias don't you worry we
got all the numbers from all the movies
in round two and may i just say how
impressed i am at all of my evil
children not only did they turn out a
ton of entertaining flicks in their
heyday they also did really well
according to the critics in fact three
of our five competitors today can brag
about a fresh tomato meter average
across all of their feature films can
you guess who it is i'll give you a hint
it ain't the round one victor no the
mummy's overall average is barely above
40 percent despite starting out hot
1932's the mummy is at a sterling 88
percent on the tomato meter at the 1940
follow-up the mummy's hand is also fresh
however the mummified peeps wouldn't see
the fresh light of day again until 1999
when hard targets arnold vosler was the
primary villain he's a great and hard
target which is
56 of the tomato meter that's uh
that's close to fresh and it has no
impact on the match at hand whatsoever
so here comes a truly fresh flick undead
and rotting though he may be let's give
dracula another fresh franchise overall
at universal his overall tomato meter
score is 66 percent average which is
fascinating when you consider that
dracula untold only earn 25 percent
but dracula's next lowest score is 55
percent and the property gets a big
fresh boost from both 1931 films dracula
at 94 percent and the spanish version of
dracula at a hundred percent son of
dracula and abbott and castella meet
frankenstein in which dracula shows up
are also fresh and speaking of that big
gigantic psychopathic zombie
frankenstein may not smell fresh but he
is on a tomato meter 74
is his two lifetime average and that
number would be much higher if not for
his run in the early 1940s the world was
at war for flicks like the house of
frankenstein but the franchise's career
started out with super fresh flicks like
frankenstein and bride of frankenstein
the og is a perfect 100 percent and his
fiancee's movie is at 98 percent it's
actually a fresh family because son of
frank is at 95
after all of his universal iterations
it's actually the wolfman who i can
blame for weighing frankenstein down
their movie predictably titled
frankenstein meets the wolf man is only
at 25
which is a good clue that the wolf man
is the other rotten creature on our list
but he gets much closer than the mummy
did to freshness missing out by only 5
for an overall average of 55 on the
tomato meter sammy hagar's driving
nemesis 55 was arrived at here thanks to
fresh films like 1940s the wolfman the
first time lon chaney jr played the role
at 90
henry hall originated the character with
1935's the werewolf of london which is
also fresh at 77 percent and yes warren
zevon's tuned 40 years later would be a
perfect 100
if we had a tomato meter for music
anybody on that yet
anybody been reading my letters that
leaves the invisible team as
frankenstein's chief competition in this
round and there's only one movie in its
entire history that is rotten the
revenge of the invisible man from 1944
at 40 percent and again look at the year
it's almost like we didn't need any more
horrors in the world when the entire
planet was at war but staying power
matters and both 1933's the invisible
man and 2020s reboot are above 90
percent on the tomato meter with the
original notching 94 and the newest
iteration earning 91
meanwhile movies that do not count like
hollow man and hello man 2 are both
rotten did you know there was a hollow
man 2 and then it starred christian
slater
well now you do overall it's the
invisible man's 75.1 percent average
putting on a ritz against frankenstein's
74
this may be too close to call so let's
check out the audience score to render a
verdict i'll show you who i am and what
i am
look he's all eaten away
and once again it's the invisible
bookends doing the freshening up the
1930s and the 2020 versions are at 85
and 88 percent respectively abbott
castella meeting up with the invisible
fella is the only other time that the
audience got the property to fresh by
contrast frankenstein has four fresh
films on this metric and only diffs
below 40 once thanks to house of dracula
at 29
so we can blame the vampire for that one
right i mean it's his house the
invisible man's revenge sets the low bar
24
the invisible woman only earned 26
and the invisible agent climbed to just
33
overall the audience score sways heavily
in favor of frankie as he's fresh for
his average at 63 percent the invisible
couple put up a good fight landing at a
54 average but in the end it's only the
good doctor and his most famous patient
that are fresh on both the tomato meter
and the audience score frankenstein
takes round two and ties it up at the
top with the invisible man it's one to
one round three villains
now we really get to sink our fangs and
wrap our arms around the stars of these
celebrated universal pictures it's the
baddest of the bad that will be crowned
the best of the best in this round who
is the best villain in terms of
character story depth evil and overall
scariness
and based on those qualities when it's a
full moon get your coors light ready and
crank the bob seeger because you're
gonna need all the silver bullets you
can find the wolfman kicks us off here
and also acts as a fun gateway for a
walk down memory lane come on kids to
old timey hollywood we go juan chaney jr
was made famous by his multiple
portrayals of universal baddies but it
was his father who was named guest juan
cheney who first walked with the queen
back in 1923 for the hunchback of notre
dame giving universal their very first
horror movie hit chaney then endured
even more extensive makeup for the
phantom of the opera in 1925 that's back
when andrew lloyd webber still had 23
years ago before appearing on earth for
practical purposes those films are not
in competition here today also left out
in the swamp is the creature from the
black lagoon the poor guy is the rodney
dangerfield of the universal classic
monsters but i will give him respect in
a later round for now it is lon chaney
ii engineering a bid for the wolf man to
get on the board but henry hall played a
mainstream werewolf first with june
lockhart and benicio del toro also
playing versions in subsequent decades
the most classic wolf man in the movie
is larry talbott and in a weird way
becoming a wolf person might have been
good for his coat of chivalry as a
regular joe he's kind of a creep that
spies on gwen in her bedroom come on
dude but when he morphs into a creature
thanks to groundbreaking makeup effects
from jack pierce the howling commences
rick baker and dave elsie would later
win an oscar for their work on the 2010
version
as a villain the wolfman is without
question terrifying both as an
individual entity and the psychological
concept that this could happen to any of
us we've all woken up naked in the woods
before but few of us went on murderous
rampages under a full moon the night
before
another reluctant entry in this round
would be frankenstein who is the
accepted name of the monster even though
that's the last name of the doctor that
brings the big guy back to life it's
still unclear who the real evil in that
series is is it the reanimated corpse
the obsessive practitioner of medicine
is it ap bio class they all scheme to
make an enduring story that began with
tragedy with boris karloff in the first
film and then saw the creature come into
his own and feel all the high school
dance feelings opposite his betrothed
pretorius and bride of frankenstein the
scares in these films initially come at
the hands of a terrifying overbearing
presence but once we get to know frank a
little better you kind of want him to
succeed in life and meet bud and lou for
some comedic hijinks the mummy similarly
gets by was scarce from the first look
reanimated horror of seeing a dead
person stroll with bandages unraveling
with every step but the first mummy
flick also starring boris karloff is
more about the obsession that imotep
feels towards helen played by zeta johan
love being a force stronger than death
is the primary theme here but the
sequels did hone in on an even more
sinister mummy hell-bent on death
destruction and revenge all the stuff we
love
a true villain in every sense of the
word is dr jack griffin that name
doesn't ring a bell he also goes by the
moniker the invisible man claude reigns
is note perfect in his role that
originated the character on the big
screen in 1933 as an adaptation from h.g
wells's classic novel griffin's
invisibility power is initially treated
as an affliction he wants to cure but
that hippocratic oath obedience quickly
subsides giving way to his longing for
power and perversity you could write off
some of his actions as his desire to win
over flora played by gloria stewart but
i can't rectify acts of terrorism and
murdering dozens of innocent civilians
that way the invisibility was a lab
accident but it made one of the more
truly terrifying characters in cinematic
history whether it was science gone
wrong or a fancy technological suit
that's providing the ability it's the
most human of any of these monsters that
could win this round
but wait what's that
good god that's count dracula's music
aren't you drinking
i never drink
why
again i love all of my evil entities
equally but drag you has got to be the
most famous of anyone in contention
today a legend rooted with some kind of
historical truth he was brought to life
or death first by bella lugosi in 1931
while carlos valerius played the titular
character in the spanish version that
same year bram stoker made this
character a mythological titan but the
film version also took as much
inspiration from a well-received stage
play from the 1920s that starred a
hungarian actor named you guessed it
bella lugosi he would lobby hard to
reprise his role on the big screen and
along with him came the suave sexually
in touch iteration of the vampire that
we see in the play lugosi cast a large
shadow over anyone else stepping into
the role but other dracula tales offered
valuable additions to the war son of
dracula is the first time that we see a
vampire turn into a bat on screen and
dracula's daughter is our inaugural time
seeing a human side of the creature of
the night as countess zeleska feels
remorse and reluctance about her
frightening abilities
no one is more famous or intimidating
than count dracula and in case you were
wondering yes juan chaney jr also
starred in a film in this franchise
leading the son of dracula but it's the
one role that juan's kid didn't play
that is winning me over here all of our
competitors have some human redemption
aspect of their villainous presences
dracula and the invisible man seem the
least affected by this and who could
blame them they have the coolest powers
it's the classic would you rather
invisibility or flight what gets me
swayed towards the invisible bunch is
that the human side that yearns for love
can get dark fast and once it goes down
that road it ain't never coming back
dracula is truly terrifying but classy
about it and you usually see him coming
actually some tellings of the tale
indicate that he needs an invitation to
come over and bite your neck so lock
your doors and draw the curtains and
don't let them in the problem is an
invisible person might already be inside
your abode literally right now while i'm
talking to you could be an invisible
person right behind you
these monsters are all crazy scary but
it's the one that also makes you think
you're crazy that gets the win in this
round there's a little redemption for
the invisible man that power made him
mad and now we can't even trust our own
eyes anymore invisibility upsets the
ultimate coffin napper here and gets a
point for their team it's one to one to
one and dracula and the wolf man are
still looking to get on the board
round four
it's alive
there may not be a more iconic line in
all of film history than those legendary
words explained by colin clive's dr
henry frankenstein and it makes a fun
title i get the shout out to kickoff
this round which is going to be won by
which franchise has the best moments
which set of flicks has the best scares
creeps and impactful sequences of all
well we might as well start with the
good bad doctor now i know what it feels
like to be god is how that momentous
scene in the first frankenstein film
concludes and it opens up a pandora's
box of questions for us the audience to
sort through what is truly scarier a
creature or the man who made it up it
remains up for debate who the real
villain of frankenstein is but the
monster makes a strong case when he
tosses a little girl into a pool
if he's not malicious he at least
doesn't know his own strength
he may not be a smart man but he does
know what love is provided the love is
just as strange as is the case with
bride of frankenstein one of the
highlights of that movie is the unique
chemistry on display in scenes like when
the monster simply offers her a drink
attraction is the most powerful elixir
of all as we'd see in the mummy films as
well boris karloff's sad eyes add an
emotional depth to imo temp's mummified
remains and we feel the centuries of
yearning when they're laid upon helen of
course it's a horror movie so he's gonna
have to kill her in order to resurrect
true love and the entire horror genre
can be summed up by ralph's reaction to
seeing the mummy walk away he screams
and then he starts laughing maniacally
as if his body can't find the correct
way to express the overwhelming fear
that he's currently experiencing and
really isn't that how we all react when
we see something in a movie theater that
scares us we all react we get scared and
then we have a good laugh together
before bracing for the next scene the
newer mummy films also have some strong
sequences in a more indiana jones style
type adventure like a daring boat escape
or a sandstorm in 1999's the mummy and a
fun double-decker bus battle across
london in the mummy returns
and if it's yeti's fighting you want and
really who doesn't go back and revisit
tomb of the dragon emperor despite its
many misfires i'm also going to give
props to the tom cruise starring mummy
for the sequence that features russell
crowe as dr jekyll it's an all-too-short
tease as to what we could have gotten
with the failed reboot of the dark
universe the 2010 wolf man similarly
failed to live up to its namesake but
there's still lots of fun werewolf
carnage to be enjoyed such as one
frightful forest battle where heads get
separated from their bodies and one of
the highlights of any werewolf film is
the first time we see the transformation
from human to wolf and the 1941 turn is
nothing short of revolutionary i also go
on record as saying that abbing castella
meet frankenstein is a highlight for lon
chaney jr as the wolf man his
transformation is fun there as well and
it's my favorite of any of the bud and
lou meet classic monster films who can
we get to do that today melissa mccarthy
and tiffany haddish you all want to do
this maybe a danny mcbride cameo
i like this movie take my money now the
original invisible man still holds up
today thanks to director james whale and
team's groundbreaking use of lighting
and visual effects when dr griffin
reveals what he's become it's utterly
terrifying and his laugh is icing on the
cake the speech referencing terrible
power becomes a theme for the entire
film and it was a very bold move back in
the 1930s to show a villain go on a
killing spree of that magnitude the
light and shadow usage even paved the
way for some of the camera tricks that
orson welles would utilize in citizen
kane so much of the invisible man's
power over others is a psychological
advantage we can't see him and other
people around us think we're nuts which
makes us feel like we're going mad this
is played expertly in 2020's version
when elizabeth moss is out of dinner
putting the puzzle pieces together that
she's being framed for murder the
hallway massacre in the breakfast
sequence by director leonel are
unnerving and fun at the very same time
dracula has an opportunity in this round
and the famed neckbiter takes full
advantage out of the gate the 1931 bella
lugosi classic plays out as one long
iconic moment from his debonair look to
the vampire wives to him and van helsing
squaring off when a crucifix offers only
temporary relief
even renfeld has a particularly
memorable scene where he crawls towards
an unsuspecting victim and it cuts so we
the audience have to imagine the horrors
that might have immediately followed the
most powerful element in horror can
sometimes be our own imagination
dracula's daughter played upon the
occasional reluctance of a vampire to
embrace their twisted thirst as we see
when countess zeleska preys upon a
female victim fast forward to 1979 when
sir lawrence olivier as van helsing
confronts frank langella's dracula after
he turned van helsing's daughter into a
vampire
dads they're so overprotective
the king of the vampire scene is also a
standout and while 2014's dracula untold
should have largely remained untold i'm
still here for a good battle like when
we witnessed vlad taking on mehmed
revisiting these iconic flicks and their
sequels has been a blast but if i have
to narrow it down to one franchise's
iconic moments it's the pure cinematic
gold that is dracula frankenstein has
some all-time scenes but the singular
horror movie villain throughout all of
time has been the count bella lugosi set
the standard for how a baddie should
look and act and move in a movie and the
rest of his brethren have been playing
catch-up ever since dracula wins the
round and will apparently not celebrate
by drinking wine we're deadlocked at the
top at one point a piece and wolfman he
got one more round to catch us and now
it's time for the wild card round
franchisability
as much as we're celebrating these
classic universal movie monsters it
can't be overlooked how disappointing
the recent dark universe failure was we
had a who's who of a-listers ready to
revive all these essential properties
and it just got fumbled away inside the
red zone and the biggest reason for our
collective sadness about all of this is
that these franchises have so much
potential well we will have to wait
unfortunately for a lot longer to get
another shot at some reboots let's take
a look at which property gives us the
best chance for a successful launch
dracula is an easy answer just because
of the enduring popularity of vampire
war film franchises like blade
underworld and twilight prove that
multiple audience bases are willing to
bask in the catacombs of a castle or the
overcast skies of the pacific northwest
in hopes of more blood sucking tails
dracula untold was already seven years
ago and the legacy of the count bears
consideration dracula had a daughter and
a son whose films also brought something
new to the table and george hamilton and
gary oldman they also had nice spins as
the fanged favorite but how do you cram
all that lore and all that history into
a new dracula story are we vampired out
at this point and can we accept yet
another reboot of the world's most
famous a positive fan
twilight and underworld also had
werewolves and the wolfman's attempted a
new legacy is even older than dracula
untold eleven years on what a new
wolfman makes sense lon chaney jr
appeared in every one of today's
franchises with the exception of the
invisible man but it was as the wolfman
where he found the most success and with
a 2010 cast that included the likes of
benicio del toro anthony hopkins emily
blunt and hugo weaving how could it not
have spawned another killer franchise
internal issues during production forced
the hand of just added director joe
johnston and the production suffered
from divergent opinions within the
studio we couldn't get it right with
that team what chance does anyone else
have to revive
poor wolfy
the invisible man poses an interesting
choice here he'll never be raided on a
par with dracula or frankenstein as far
as fame or breakfast cereals go but
maybe that helped with a 2020 reboot
being so successful and well received
we have less expectations that's fair
and we weren't anticipating an mcu like
our universe to be spun from this one
movie as we were with the 2017 mummy
yeah that mummy got stretched in way too
many directions when the focus should
have been just on telling one good scary
story or making a dr jekyll movie
starring russell crowe right out of the
gate i still want that flick
but now that we have a solid entry in a
new invisible man franchise could that
be the linchpin for sequels and
spin-offs does it even want to be that
the mummy certainly had high hopes as
did the 1999 reboot which did boffo box
office and spawned its own popular
property and again that ride it's as fun
as it is short it lasts like 45 seconds
it's worth the wait i promise you
now the mummy wore would have made some
sense to kick off a new shared universal
well universe because its lore takes us
so much further back than any of the
other properties in competition today
but it also feels like it can stand
alone and just entertain us for decades
simply by spinning yarns that range from
the horrific to the swashbuckling the
only issue we gotta wait a while to get
the taste of that 2017 version out of
our mouths
the prospect of having angelina jolie
play the bride of frankenstein was
certainly intriguing but at some point
we gotta wonder if these properties
could work alongside the appetite of
modern audiences would the madness of dr
frankenstein hold up better than the
obsession of the mummy or the untamed
violence of the wolfman can this
technological spin placed on the
invisible man propel that franchise to
new heights or should we simply go back
to square one at dracula's transylvania
pad it's a great question that has been
bantered around in the highest halls of
hollywood and it worked so well decades
ago that it was abbott and costello you
could credit for launching the first
shared universe everyone who is anyone
in universal horror was around when
those fellas met frankenstein and this
was going on when captain america was
still a popsicle in the middle of
nowhere it's the invisible man that most
recently proved that audiences still
have a mass desire to see classic horror
properties reimagined and that's why it
gets the edge in this round kicking off
a new decade by embracing modern tech
and weaving in our classic concept of
who this villain is was in stark
contrast to the efforts made by the
mummy frankenstein dracula and the wolf
man to go back to basics in the same way
that we may not need to see uncle ben
get off yet again in a spider-man film
perhaps now we take a look at how those
classic properties could translate into
a modern world dracula will always be
the goat as far as iconic movie villains
and every one of these initial films as
well as the many sequels deserve to be
revisited as both entertainment and
exhibits in the evolution of cinema but
right now it's a person or people that
we can't even see that has the best shot
of making a fun scary bankable franchise
team invisible wins the round and in a
considerable upset takes the match
apologies to lon chaney juan cheney jr
and their entire extended family for
selecting the one character that he
didn't play and making them the winner
lon chaney jr didn't take up acting
until after his father passed away and
he initially went by his real name
creighton cheney before going by his
more famous moniker for obvious reasons
his on-screen representations paved the
way for so much of what we horror fans
now enjoy and if it's a shared universe
that we really really want
can we just reboot monster squad
remember that movie it's got everyone
and the creature from the black lagoon
and speaking of that scene in the
original when the creature is mimicking
the human woman swimming just yards
above him still scary still
heartbreaking good stuff buddy i got
your back
this is of course all just my opinion
now i turn it over to you world who is
your favorite classic universal movie
monster and which franchise do you see
involving itself next hit me up at
social media at mark ellis and you know
i still remember the exhilaration i felt
when i created my twitter account i hit
confirm and i screamed alive
it's alive it's an egg responded to me
calling me a dope
been all downhill ever since
thanks twitter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you